We have someone here we want you to meet. Yeah, all you to do is just Clooney Trumper and your gold. Or do yourself
Oh please, I Clooney charmed you the day we met
What, what are you talking about? I did. I gave you gravity Clooney with a little bit of three kings mixed in. You never even saw it coming
I'm not in social media at all
Someday I want to be able to tell my children that their mother and I were at the same place at the same time that I had got up the courage to say hi
I'm Jed. Tasha. It's really sweet, but if I meet a guy I have to be able to Google him like a deep gook
I want to know his likes and his unlikes. Don't you mean dislikes
Hey, Jed. I love that picture of you with Usher. Yeah, that was a fun night. When was that?
Listen you're obviously a gifted artist I
Want to help you help me with what?
I'm interested to see if I can take someone like you and grow their following to a significant place
Jed, you are gonna be the guy every girl wants to be with. Frankie Doinghan. Jed!
I have not seen you since high school! Actually that's not true, we're facebook friends
She has got your life looking so incredible. I mean I'm your closest friend and you are not that exciting
Oh my god. Usher, he's here. Relax, there's no way he's seen the picture. The picture's been liked over a million times
Yo, Usher!
Just act like a Fan.
Jed right? From Vegas
How are you?
Ah man, cool
You remember when we would spend maximum an hour a week in front of a computer
I used to have to write things down on paper. Whoa four million followers. Who's this? Just a regular guy. Good work Tash
Why did you start lying about yourself? I just didn't think the real me was enough
I'm not gonna get that
Yeah you are gonna get that. This is the universe reaching out to you in the form of Usher
You don't screen Usher's phone calls
It's a miracle
Where are you going? I don't know let's find out